[Music]
hi steve okay hey alyssa uh everyone you
can see right here i am so excited today
because i am being joined by the one the
only alyssa milano alyssa how you doing
today i'm doing okay it's you know it's
the day before my movie drops on netflix
so i'm i'm feeling all of the things i'm
feeling
excited and nervous and
and all of all of the emotions
yeah yeah i mean i'm excited for you and
what's so awesome about you is you do so
many things and
in that you are an executive producer as
well in this film and you're an author
so what was it about the book brazen
virtue that made you think this should
be a film
well first of all um norah roberts is
one of my favorite writers and she just
everything she puts out to me is such a
page turner
um and this book was was no exception um
but also it just it it taps into
everything we love about true crime
stories uh which i'm obsessed with um
uh you know it's got it's got everything
it's about a crime writer who
uh really fights out of love to find
the person that killed her sister
and it's got mystery and emotion and
uh so much heart and action and romance
um and great performances and beautiful
set designs and you know monica mitchell
is our director and she just
uh led the cast and crew to make a
really beautiful
fun movie so i'm really excited for
everyone to see it
yeah and you know it's interesting it's
someone who has seen it i love this film
and i think you're amazing in it and
you've been doing this acting for a
while but because like i mentioned you
do so many things do you still find that
same joy in acting as you do when you
first started
i do i do i think you know i think for
me what is exciting is this
this new place that the industry is in
it's very different than
uh you know when i was in my 20s and and
mostly men we're running the industry
and i think we're telling different
stories from different perspectives and
that's something that's really exciting
to me and i think
you know
you so often hear that
women after a certain age don't
uh find great roles in the entertainment
industry and i feel
that the roles that i have found or that
have found me um have actually been more
exciting than than anything i've i've
done
yeah and that's exciting too and you've
also done so much to help that movement
industry which is really cool so i also
want to ask too i love that you're a
huge baseball fan and i feel like we're
overdue for a great baseball movie um so
i was wondering would you ever
considered making one and maybe you
would put on your instagram this story
about the first female manager in miley
baseball is just something maybe
that is an incredible story
for sure um i think baseball movies are
hard enough to sell i'm not sure we
could
sell a baseball movie about a a woman in
the sport but i am willing to give it a
try my very dear friend is jen welter
who is the first nfl
uh coach
who who broke the glass
sideline she likes to say and she's just
such an incredibly
um
powerful and inspiring woman
and i'm sure this this woman who is uh
breaking
the the glass uh dugout
is equally as awesome
yeah and i it's exciting to see all
these stories and then you get excited
to see it hopefully come to screen and
um
also before i let you go
could we see more stories with grace in
the future or maybe more nora roberts
adaptations you think it's so funny
because um
you're not the first person to ask that
today
so uh maybe
maybe i feel like you know when we were
shooting it we were kind of like
between me and malachi and sam and how
uh different our acting styles are and
our uh what we brought to our characters
and the dynamics between us we were like
this would be a good series like this
threesome of
fighting crime
um so maybe
yeah so
everybody check out brazen is out on
netflix tomorrow and you're gonna love
it alyssa crushes it here as grace
alyssa thank you so much for joining me
today i hope to talk to you in the
future one day thank you for your
support i appreciate you